fabrice epelboin bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors la
plateforme internationale qui compte
aujourd'hui 1 milliard d'utilisateurs
annoncé hier l'ouverture prochaine en
irlande de son premier centre de données
pour ses utilisateurs européens
quel est l'objectif de tik tok
l'objectif est de faire croire que le
fait de localiser les données en europe
apporte une forme de garantie ce qui est
un écran de fumée
qu'il s'agisse de d'entreprises telles
que les gars pas qu'ils localisent leurs
datacenters en europe où des chinois
qu'ils localisent dans data center en
europe
ça ne change absolument rien au problème
typiquement le cloud date pour parler de
du versant américain autorise l'état
américain allait se servir
là où bon lui semble quelle que soit la
localisation de dota center et qui plus
est la sphère prisme a révélé que de
toute façon cette collaboration avec
lieu évidemment il paraît à peu près
certain que les chinois ou l'équivalent
d'un programme quelques prisme donc lui
les craintes sont tout à fait fondées
donc on doit toujours s'inquiéter en
france et en europe justement d'un
traitement des données personnelles
alors c'est l'une l'un des aspects
géopolitiques intéressant dans la paire
titeuf c'est que donald trump a forcé la
main pour que microsoft rachète une
partie de type top pas la totalité est
la partie qui concerne la lépi proche
allié des états unis ceux qui sont issus
du réseau et sont à l'exception notable
de la grande bretagne et est donc
quelque part c'est un signal très clair
envoyé à boris johnson pour ce qui est
de sa sa protection par la puissance
américaine
mais c'est aussi un constat très dur à
faire vis-à-vis europe
tik tok en europe restauration
souveraineté chinoise est donc la même
que le même problème d'espionnage et
d'ingérence pas s'opposer à tous les
dirigeants européens
on l'a dit tik tok est accusé par
washington d'espionner ses utilisateurs
pour le compte de pékin ces accusations
sont elles fondées selon vous sondez non
au sens où il faudrait des preuves en
tant qu'elles soient fondées légitime
évidemment comment imaginer un instant
que le programme de surveillance chinois
ne soient pas au minimum à la hauteur de
programmes américains le pouvoir
américain on le sait depuis 2015
consiste entre autres à une
collaboration ouverte est totale entre
les gaffes et la msa
il paraît à peu près évident qui a
l'équivalent en chine donc non encore
une fois ce n'est pas fondée parce qu'il
faut des preuves pour fonder une
accusation mais le soupçon est plus que
légitime
on parle de toc toc mais on parle
également de l'application plus tôt du
réseau social chinois ou chattes
est-ce que voilà vous pensez que
d'autres pays vont suivre un petit peu
les ailes n'est pas de washington c'est
tout l'enjeu notamment pour l'europe
l'inde a suivi les pas de washington
doivent bien avant washington pour
enseigner l'art washington en watts et
le pas sur l'un maintenant l'attention
se focalise sur l'europe
est ce que l'europe va finalement à
naître se partager entre deux formes de
souveraineté sur son territoire la
souveraineté américaine et la
souveraineté chinoise
sachant que l'europe elle-même n'a
aucune forme de souveraineté sur le
cyber ou est ce que l'europe a décidé
d'assumer d'être une colonie américaine
et du coup de repousser l'envahisseur
chinois
on va voir sachant que authentique toc
est une application rigolote très à la
mode et qui en ce moment connaît un
succès incroyable autant ri cha c'est
complètement autre chose c'est un réseau
social gigantesque avec un nombre de
fonctionnalités absolument incroyable
c'est une application totalement unique
par rapport à ce qu'on a l'habitude
d'utiliser ou en occident qui sont
plutôt d utilisation très simple d
application très simple
là on a affaire avec luc chatel
véritable boîte à outils d'une
complexité extrême
si jamais ce type d'application devenu
populaire en occident il est évident que
oui chat aurait un avantage que ni
facebook ni google ne pourrait rattraper
donc le là on pourrait avoir quelque
chose qui d'un point de vue conquête de
territoire en dehors de la chine serait
beaucoup plus menaçant que des coques
quelles conséquences voilà cette
décision des états unis va t elle avoir
sur tik tok elle-même sur tik tok
bresson une perte de valeur mais en même
temps une bonne potentiellement une
affaire juteuse avec microsoft sur tes
limites chatte une déconfiture en bourse
le cours de bourse a plongé de 10% et
probablement une multitude de
problématiques qui se posent entre la
diaspora chinoise et les familles
restées en chine parce que widget est
aujourd'hui et depuis longtemps
l'outil qui permet à toutes ces familles
de communiquer de rester unis donc là
dessus il ya toujours moyen de
contourner ces formes de censure mais ça
va obliger beaucoup de monde à
contourner des dispositifs de censure
merci beaucoup fabrice epelboin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes enseignant à sciences po et
spécialiste des réseaux sociaux